there was one group of astronomers who
all thought it was around fifty and
another group of astronomers who all
thought it was around 100 and so there
was a big argument running for decades
and these two camps were were you know
forever at war with one another coming
back with more and more evidence to
support theirs and to trash the other
camps ideas as to how they should
measure this Hubble constant it's really
it's a story that sort of goes back to
the early years of the 20th century when
astronomers first found out that all the
galaxies or nebulae as they were known
then are all running away from us and
this caught some consternation because
it looked like there was some kind of
cosmic halitosis that for some reason
all these galaxies were running away
from our own Milky Way but subsequently
it was realized that this was actually
down to the expansion of the entire
universe and everything was running away
from us just because the whole place is
getting bigger and this quantity the
Hubble constant is really a measure of
how quickly the universe is getting
bigger so the equation is that V the
velocity that the things running away
from it is H the Hubble constants times
D the distance away the constant is just
the number and it's unfortunately
astronomers measure in really strange
units because we really usually measure
velocities of galaxies the natural unit
to use is kilometers per second and the
distance the galaxies are typically
measured in mega parsecs millions of
parsecs so the Hubble constant has these
weird units of kilometers per second per
megaparsec and in those strange units
it's a number that comes out somewhere
around 70 where's it kept is a number in
your head or is it written down or I
know that might be Steve that's that's a
really good question because actually
until maybe five ten years ago the word
we didn't actually know what the value
was and in fact bizarrely there were two
schools so I said that the current value
our best estimate is somewhere around 70
but until five ten years ago there was
one group of astronomers who all thought
it was around 50 and another group of
astronomers who all thought it was
around 100 and so there was a big
argument running for decades and these
two camps were were you know forever at
war with one another coming up with more
and more evidence to support theirs and
to trash the other camps ideas as to how
they should measure this Hubble constant
and now the value is pretty well tied
down there is no kind of official
sanction value that different people use
different values it's just important
when you use it that when you write a
scientific paper you say what value of
the Hubble constant you actually used so
that if other people disagree with you
they can always go back and redo the
calculation
the Hubble constant is not really a
constant it's a bit of a misnomer to
call it a constant because actually it's
changing with time since it's a measure
of how fast the universe is expanding
because there are various forces acting
on that expansion the pull of gravity is
trying to slow down the expansion and
then more recently we've discovered this
mysterious stuff called dark energy
which is actually making that expansion
speed up with time it means that this
constant is actually varied over the
lifetime of the universe and so in order
to make sure we understand exactly where
we are usually instead of just calling H
we usually call it H naught so it's H
with a little zero after it just to say
that that's that particular value of the
Hubble constant as it is today it's only
within the last 5 years we've even
really measured it now today this value
of H naught and trying to measure the
Hubble constant as it was in the past or
how it's going to be in the future is
something that we're really struggling
to do it's probably one of the next
great things in astronomy you're least
in cosmology and understanding the
large-scale properties of the universe
is really to see how this Hubble
constant evolved with time and use that
to tell us about the properties of the
universe whether it's going to be around
forever
whether it's going to expand faster and
faster but whether it will ultimately
collapse on itself in a Big Crunch